well tell us uh Joy uh so you you you
take care of these animals how does one
even get into zookeeping it is a very
competitive field so a lot of times when
we're out there scrubbing poo like is a
lot of our job they will turn to their
kid and be like see if you don't you
know go to school you'll end up like
that and it's actually we get a lot of
schooling I got a master's degree in
biological sciences and yes scrubbing
poo is part of it but wait a minute
you're telling me that you're at the zoo
taking of the animals and sometimes
you're picking up poo and you'll hear a
parent say to their kid yeah if you
don't study hard you'll end up like that
one have you actually heard someone say
that these dicks yes that's terrible
first of all I'm sorry I said it
uh I was uh I was in a bad mood and I I
was in Ohio and I just was tryed to
check out the zoo and uh I was with my
kid and he said I don't have to go to
college and I so whatever I was your kid
you just said that to a random kid I
took it I said it to a random child he
started crying and said who the who the
are you you should bust into those
parents' houses when they're wiping
their kids bums and changing their
diapers and say that to them yeah and
then you'll be guilty of breaking yes
yeah that is a crime so so Joy you take
care of all these different animals uh
tell me about tortoises because I've
never connected with tortoises I like
animals but I don't connect with the
tortoise I just don't oh my go on an
emotional level and maybe they maybe
they're on to me maybe they know
something I don't you know they're
picking up on a bad Vibe but I've never
connected with the tortoise in fact most
animals with a shell and I don't get
along I don't like a shrimp um I don't
like any kind of mollusk if it's got a
shell I can I tell it to go to hell
that's my motto so I'm not quite a
gimmick yeah uh the tortoise tell us
about it okay so they're amazing and
granted yes you can have some that are
like no I don't want anything to do with
you but um we and personally in my care
um we'll take care of our alabra
tortoises that are um 76 and 56 years
old and Bubba is the oldest animal at
the zoo he weighs about 567 pounds
Sunny's about 100 pounds uh lighter than
he is you have a 76y old
tortoise does it talk a lot about how
now Eisenhower Eisenhower was a
president he he was a command Commander
Chief but also he had led troops in the
field unlike our current presidents take
it easy
taurise does uh I mean can you sense the
wisdom of an animal that's been around
for 76 years well I I don't know that I
would go straight to wisdom but
charismatic absolutely um hands down so
even just walking in to their yard and
you say their name um a lot of times
when they're not napping they'll perk up
and they'll start coming over and
walking over to you and they love
scratches on their neck and their shells
and they stand up nice and tall and they
they were a I mean they're the a day
brightener every Christmas season it's
the same thing demands for more podcast
episode comes in and we've got to meet
those demands we got to mail out those
podcasts we got to get them in the mail
well guess what with stamps.com all you
need is a computer and printer then
you're ready for that Holiday Rush you
know what I'm saying no I'm remember
last year when we were stuffing podcast
into envelopes and licking them and
putting on the stamps it was crazy in
here no more not with stamps.com they
even send you a free scale so you have
everything you need to get started cuz
whenever I go to mail stuff out I'm like
where's my scale well they got the scale
ready there for you now taking care of
orders on the go is even easier with the
stamps.com mobile app if you need a
package pickup you can easily schedule
it through your stamps.com
dashboard and if you sell products
online stamps.com seamlessly connects
with every major Marketplace and
shopping cart get your business ready
for the holiday Rush get started with
stamps.com today sign up at stamps.com
Conan for a special offer that includes
a 4-week trial plus free postage and a
free digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com Conan doesn't it take them 40
minutes to come over to where you are
they're very slow aren't they such beef
with tortois well I'm sorry but it
depends depends if they are on a mission
they can move quickly okay not in my
experience they can move slowly yeah but
a lot of times if you have a good you
know if they want to hang out with you
they're going to come over so a lot of
times if we have to bring them inside
for the evening because it's Ohio and in
the Autumn and early spring it gets too
cold for them to be outside we like to
encourage them to come inside that's
where they get their dinner and also you
know they'll get encouragement for
coming in so they'll see us back there
start Trucking their way in sometimes
they do a little lap but yeah they come
over and all right I'm going to be
honest with you Joy I've never met a
charismatic tortoise ever I have to
agree ever you need to spend more time
with can I say something your bar for
Charisma is super low you were like oh
my God these tortoises are so
charismatic a really Joy tell us well
you call their name and they lift their
head then slowly make their way to you
and if you scratch them they tend to
seem to be okay with it wow that's a
real
JFK well but but here I am talking to
you oh
so I see so I have the equal amount of
Charisma as a tortoise he how do
tortoises
made very
carefully Sor so um the males oftentimes
on the underside of their shell will
have a like a concave um indent so that
I have that fale I have a concave
indent caused me a lot of Shame he'll
he'll Mount the female and uh then they
kind of will tuck their tail underneath
where their CLA is and uh they'll mate
oftentimes the males will make noises uh
they grunt you usually can hear several
buildings over when the tortoises are
mating because it's a very loud yes
grunt like what
oh well yeah but smaller ones that could
be a tortoise or anyone I know I mean
I'm going to be honest with you I'm a I
might part
tortoise I'm concave down there and I
go well oh come on no why don't give me
body shame I'm telling you about a very
I'm opening up here then you should be
more into the tortoises yeah is this
self because you yeah you you see
yourself in them and maybe my shell is
my sarcastic exterior yeah yeah we went
deep uh now I just said some stuff and
then we moved on
um okay well uh okay that's how the and
you also take care of penguins yep tell
us describe these penguins are they the
penguins that we see in cartoons just
that run around in bow ties and stuff is
it is it those Penguins so they are a
warm climate species of penguins that
are in America so
stupid I can't believe you're putting up
with any of this Joy you you have all
this education and knowledge I'm like ah
and these the ones that have the you
know the bow ties
they wait tables in
cartoons to be fair we do have an Oswald
Cobble pot to play into that okay oh wow
that's the name of one oh oh and he runs
it like it's his Colony too so he is the
villain is that an emperor penguin no so
um they are humble so they're South
American or Peruvian Penguins they're
they're mediumsized they're smaller than
a king and Emperors are the largest
what's the largest penguin how big would
it get they can probably stand about
well oh like species wise or like our
Penguins sorry I no just any penguin I'm
just curious what's the biggest penguin
in the world you want to know if you can
take it well let's let me hear the size
first and then I'll I I'll determine if
I can fight it I don't work with
Emperors but I do believe they're
probably closer to three and half four
feet I would have to fact check that
because I've never worked with them but
the ones I work with come up to my knees
so they're like what's their what's
their personality what's the personality
of these penguins that you work with uh
the level of sass is probably a mixture
of cats and high school girls oh I would
say wow okay very sassy sassy and they
get into it with each other and sort of
gossip about each other yeah oh they're
always yelling at each other absolutely
hanging out at the mall they try on
makeup but never buy
it sorry they steal
scrunchies come on they steal a lot of
things you guys don't know anything
about teenage girls I know all about
them I know all about teenage girls
okay uh so uh steal scrunchies well you
did um and flamingos you work with
flamingos absolutely so they are taller
than I am some of them um we have H A
Flock that it has been my goal to name
every single bird when I first started
because they were just numbered and I
thought that was kind of a copout I did
that with Matt and Sona when they were
first worked here number eight and
number 11 don't ask me why it's not even
an order what happened in between you
don't want to know let's just say they
didn't work out um and their families
miss them
uh can someone ride a flamingo or
flamingos aren't big I'm thinking of
like an
ostrich not so much yeah no could a
tortois ride a
flamingo what are you ask in this case
Size Matters so I would say teeny tiny
yes but it would probably fall off
because flamingos are flirting walk
walking everywhere flapping wings
bathing they're they're not one to stay
still for too long can I just say that
you're a highly educated person who's
worked very hard to take care of these
animals is there some part of you that's
insulted by the idiocy of my questions I
it's kind of like the spice of life so
I'm not insulted good but well I would
be if I were you you should be there a
lot of children that come to her Zoo
probably so she's used to it I bet you
even children don't go as low as
does the tortoise ride to
Flamingo Billy you're
[Laughter]
stupid maybe I am I mean we keep a
quotebook at work for all the questions
that we get so you know well I'm in
there now
yeah